Вітаю всіх.
Сьогодні ми у 9 класі у курсі
“Еволюції” розберемо першу тему.
Чому ж популяція є
основною одиницею еволюції?
Тема “Еволюції” у вашому підручнику
розпочинається із такої теми:
“Популяція є одиницею еволюції”.
Перш ніж почати розбиратися з
популяціями, давайте спочатку з’ясуємо,
що ми розуміємо під власне «еволюцією».
Еволюція – це розвиток,
еволюція – це процес змін.
При чому ці зміни в обов’язковому порядку
мають бути відображені
на генетичному складі,
тобто має змінитися генетичний матеріал,
для того, щоб він передавався нащадкам.
По-друге, еволюція –
це процес не просто змін,
а змін, які мають призвести до адаптації
або не адаптації організму
до умов середовища.
Відповідно ми маємо оцінювати
вклад середовища в цей процес.
У процесі еволюції види,
які в ньому беруть участь,
можуть або виникати, або зникати.
Ми часто чуємо фразу про
те, що еволюціонують види.
Дійсно, види еволюціонують.
А до чого ж тоді популяція?
Чому ми розпочинаємо
цей курс із популяції,
тобто із дрібніших одиниць ніж види?
Причин декілька.
Перша причина така, що
визначень виду є багато.
Залежно від якого визначення ми будемо
відштовхуватися, у нас група організмів,
яка називається видом, буде змінюватися.
Ну то таке, трошки філософське питання.
Друга причина в тому, що вид для еволюції
є дуже незручною одиницею.
Спробуємо розібратися на таких прикладах:
Питання 1.
Чому ж еволюціонують види,
але одиниці еволюції – популяція?
Розглянемо з такого прикладу.
Чому не еволюціонує один організм?
Уявімо ситуацію. Нехай у нас
буде якась гіпотетична миша.
Нехай відбулась якась
мутація і ця миша змінилась,
набула можливості перетравлювати
целюлозу з рослинних клітин.
Ми знаємо, що ссавці не вміють це робити.
За них це робить мікрофлора кішківника.
Але уявімо ситуацію, за якою миша
навчилась живитися целюлозою.
Звичайно, це велика перевага для неї.
Вона відтепер зможе
вижити у холодну зиму.
Вона може їсти деревину тощо.
Але чи еволюціонувала та миша, чи ні?
Ні, тому що одна миша
не може передати цю свою
набуту властивість своїм нащадкам.
Тобто нам потрібен процес розмноження.
Для процесу розмноження
нам потрібно декілька мишей.
Як ви бачите, навіть, якщо один якийсь
організм набуває якоїсь корисної ознаки,
то для еволюції це взагалі ніщо, якщо
цей організм цю ознаку передати не здатен.
Давайте розглянемо зворотній приклад.
Чому не еволюціонує вид?
Справа в тому, що вид – це
дуже велика група організмів,
яка не однорідна із середини.
Розглянемо на прикладі мишей
і площі, яку вони заселяють.
Миші живуть майже у будь-яких
умовах: в пустелях, в холодних краях тощо.
Уявімо ситуацію, що у нас є певний
вид мишей, який широко розселений.
Чи в однакових умовах будуть різні миші?
Ті що живуть на півдні чи на півночі.
Звичайно, що ні.
Якщо, наприклад, на півночі холодно,
то миші будуть змінюватися таким
чином, щоб запасати поживні речовини.
Миші, які на півдні, будуть
змінюватись, наприклад,
намагатися нарощувати вуха для того,
щоб відводити від організму зайве тепло.
Тобто в середині виду особини різні.
Вони поєднуються в якісь певні групи.
Всі особини в середині виду не
мають змоги вільно схрещуватись.
Південна миша не зможе
схрещуватись із північною мишею.
Не тому, що біологічно не може.
Біологічно, гіпотетично може.
Але фізично вона не
зможе добігти одна до одної.
Тобто коли ми оговорюємо
вид, ми завжди маємо на увазі,
що вид розбитий на
більш дрібні групи особин –
популяції, кожна з яких
знаходиться в певних умовах довкілля,
в середині якої організми знаходяться
під впливом одних факторів середовища.
В середині однієї популяції
особини більш однорідні між собою.
Кожна популяція зазнає впливу
різних факторів середовища.
Тому в середині кожної популяції
будуть відбуватися якісь певні зміни.
В різних популяціях ці
зміни будуть різними.
Таким чином в кожній популяції будуть
відбуватися свої еволюційні процеси.
Деякі з цих змін можуть
призвести до утворення нових видів.
Ми вже ближче підійшли
до опису популяції.
Давайте розберемося, чим
же відрізняються різні популяції,
різних особин, одна від іншої?
Перша характеристика, яку ми
розглянемо – це чисельність популяції.
Тобто скільки взагалі
особин до цієї групи входить.
Така чисельність може
дуже сильно змінюватись.
Наприклад, якщо ми
візьмемо популяцію тигрів,
то в одній популяції буде 20-30
особин. Їх не може бути більше,
оскільки більша кількість тварин
буде потребувати більшої кількості їжі,
більших територій для полювання.
Коли ця територія буде збільшуватися,
то це вже не буде одна популяція
тигрів, це вже буде кілька популяцій.
Для порівняння візьмемо популяцію комах,
наприклад, нехай це буде сарана.
В одній популяції сарани може вміститися
кількасот або навіть
кілька мільйонів особин.
Чисельність популяції залежить від того,
про який вид організмів
ми з вами говоримо.
Наступна характеристика,
не менш важлива –
це щільність популяції: кількість особин,
яка мешкає на певній площі території.
Для чого нам це знати
в еволюційному сенсі?
Як це впливає на еволюцію?
Уявіть собі
тропічні ліси, сельва
Амазонки, величезні дерева.
Деякі з цих дерев запилюються
дуже специфічними запилювачами,
наприклад, кажанами.
Дерева таких видів можуть
знаходитись на відстані
кількох кілометрів одне від одного.
Ці дерева квітнуть вночі для того,
щоб бути запиленими кажанами.
Вночі кажани облітають
цю популяцію дерев.
Вони перелітають
відстані кілька кілометрів
щоб дістатися від
одного дерева до іншого.
Якщо частину цього
лісу вирубати, а ви знаєте,
що цей процес зараз дуже активно
відбувається в амазонських лісах,
то можна раптово
вирубати ліс таким чином,
що відстань між деревами
стане занадто великою.
Кажани фізично не зможуть
долетіти від одного дерева до іншого.
Тобто процес запилення відбуватися не буде
і така популяція взагалі ризикує зникнути.
Звичайно, що такі речі
необхідно враховувати
при веденні господарської діяльності.
Щільність популяції безпосередньо
пов’язана в даному випадку з еволюцією.
Ми розглянули приклад з нашими деревами
– то така популяція просто зникне.
Еволюція для них вже не буде мати сенсу.
Вікова структура популяції описує
співвідношення особин
різних віків всередині популяції.
Якщо в популяції переважають молоді
особини та особини репродуктивного віку,
ця популяція збільшується.
Вона росте в чисельності і
буде збільшувати свій ареал.
Якщо навпаки, переважають особини похилого
віку, які не так активно розмножуються,
то така популяція буде зменшуватись.
Нащадків буде менше.
Звичайно в сенсі еволюції у такої
популяції буде менше шансів накопичити
достатню кількість змін для того, щоб
бути перетвореними на якийсь окремий вид.
Також важлива статева
структура популяції,
тобто співвідношення
самців і самок у популяції.
Зазвичай це 50/50%.
Бувають і інші співвідношення.
Наприклад, бувають випадки, коли
популяція складається лише із самиць.
Це характерно для комах, які
розмножуються партеногенетичним шляхом.
Тобто самки утворюють покоління
самок із незапліднених яєць.
Самців у популяції дуже мало.
Або всі особини популяції
на даному етапі розвитку
складаються лише із особин однієї статі.
Це також можлива біологічна річ,
це трішки нестандартна ситуація.
До чого тут еволюція, навіщо нам
оцінювати це в контексті еволюції?
Якщо ми маємо врівноважену
статеву структуру,
то передача якихось нових ознак
буде відбуватися не таким
шляхом аніж популяція,
яка розмножується партеногенетично,
або взагалі вегетативним шляхом.
Що відбувається з популяціями?
Чому вони змінюються?
Чому ми можемо говорити про
еволюцію всередині цих популяцій?
Або в еволюцію популяцій в різні види?
По-перше, в популяціях
можуть накопичуватися мутації.
Мутації – це будь-які зміни
генетичного матеріалу.
Якщо генетичний матеріал
змінений, то він може успадковуватися.
Успадковуватись будуть лише ті ознаки,
зміни яких потрапили до
статевих клітин для тих особин,
які розмножуються саме статевим шляхом.
Також має значення
таке явище як хвилі життя.
Це періодична або неперіодична
зміна чисельності особин у популяції.
Коли це відбувається, за яких умов?
Наведу такий приклад.
Уявіть собі абстрактний ліс.
Нехай в ньому живуть зайці
та хижаки, які на них полюють.
Якщо умови сприятливі для
зайців, вони будуть розмножуватись,
їх чисельність буде зростати,
щільність їх популяції буде зростати.
Але ж зайці є базою
харчування для хижаків.
З часом почне збільшуватися
популяція хижаків,
оскільки їм є чим
прогодувати свою молодь,
тому цих хижаків стане більше.
Коли збільшиться кількість хижаків,
вони почнуть активно полювати на зайців
і кількість зайців знову зменшиться.
Коли зменшиться кількість зайців, на
наступний сезон хижакам забракне їжі.
Це призведе до зменшення їх популяцій.
Тобто, хвилеподібно змінюється
чисельність популяції одного виду.
І відповідно так само хвилеподібно,
але з деякою затримкою,
змінюється чисельність популяції іншого
виду, який залежить від першого виду.
Відбуваються хвилі життя,
зміни чисельності популяції.
До чого тут еволюція взагалі?
Це має значення у тому випадку,
коли хвиля життя
знаходиться у своєму мінімумі.
Коли чисельність популяції
дуже і дуже мала мала
і трапляється якась мутація, то
вірогідність розповсюдження цієї мутації
всередині малої популяції
буде набагато вища
в порівнянні з великою популяцією,
де мутація, яка з’явилась,
загубиться в потоці змін, які
відбуваються з кожною особиною.
Тобто всі критичні
еволюційні зміни відбуваються
відбуваються і всі еволюційні
фактори найактивніше діють тоді,
коли ми маємо справу з
дуже малою популяцією.
Наступний фактор, який також
напряму з цим пов’язаний, це дрейф генів.
Це раптова зміна
співвідношення генів в
середині однієї популяції.
Давайте розглянемо це на такому прикладі.
Уявіть собі абстрактний,
неглибокий ставок,
який здатен влітку пересихати,
утворюючи кілька неглибоких калюж.
Нехай в цьому ставку живуть жаби.
Навесні, доки ставок заповнений водою,
всі ці жаби майже рівномірно
переміщуються всередині ставка.
Популяція цих жаб більш-менш рівномірна.
Коли влітку ставок пересихає та утворює
кілька калюж, може утворитися ситуація,
за якою раптово без усіляких
причин, в одній калюжі, наприклад,
опиниться переважна кількість
жаб із більш зеленим забарвленням,
а в іншій – більша кількість
жаб із бурим забарвленням.
Якщо ці калюжі надалі почнуть
існувати, як окремі водойми,
утвориться ситуація, за якою первинно
рівномірна популяція жаб розділиться.
Ми вже будемо мати справу з
двома окремими популяціями,
які будуть своїми шляхами
пристосовуватись до умов довкілля.
А трапилось це раптово, на невеликій
популяції первинних організмів.
Таке явище має назву дрейф генів –
тобто зміна співвідношення різних
генів всередині однієї популяції.
Всі ці зміни сумарно призводять
до зміни генофонду популяції.
Генофонд популяції - це
співвідношення генів у середині популяції
і поява чогось нового
– мутації, хвилі життя,
за яких можуть утворитися якісь
рідкісні ознаки, швидко розповсюдитись,
дрейф генів, який раптово
змінює співвідношення генів.
Вони всі призводять в кінцевому
випадку до зміни генофонду популяції.
Ну і що далі з цим робити?
А далі з цим робити ось що.
Коли ми вже одержали популяцію,
одержали їх кілька та зміненими,
надалі ми вже будемо розглядати
долю кожної популяції окремо.
Оцінювати, яким чином
кожна з цих популяцій
буде пристосовуватись до умов довкілля,
як вони будуть розвиватись, як
будуть змінюватись параметри популяції,
чисельність, щільність,
вікова та статева структури.
Підсумовуючи все те, про що я
говорила, можемо зробити таке резюме,
що дійсно, коли ми починаємо
обговорювати еволюційний процес,
ми маємо робити це
на саме рівні популяції.
Це саме той рівень, саме ті організми
з якими якісь зміни
відбуваються безпосередньо.